all right today is laundry day
and in typical lazy household fashion
we're just gonna throw the clothes from
upstairs
to downstairs
so we can continue watching movies and
here it comes ready
i don't know
one more one more time let's see
stay standing okay
stay standing let's see what it looks
like
here's a big one ready
oh my god this is the biggest one
i know i tricked you that's it
what's the idea monkey
you don't know
no thank you what's the idea because he
was like i have an idea and i was like
yes do that i know i heard y'all saying
well you guys are in sync that that's
the end oh cool what are you doing with
all these presents he's gonna transport
them but obviously in the kid way i told
him to move them to that table but kids
never do things the way they're supposed
to because or boys
no i wouldn't why do you think i knew
what it was that's true
um
you have to do it in the funnest ways
possible that's the truth so when he
said he has an idea i was like i would
have done the same tycoon that's cuny
good job duty you didn't know what we
were about to do no it didn't thank you
skinny
it jumped how did we tie this so it
doesn't get stuck on the
uh on the wheel pop-up engineer mine
how did i do it
i don't know
let's see a woman in engineering work
you look like you have a mustache
from this angle oh no never mind the
side angle the little blue should talk
about that i know i haven't mentioned it
but i actually got
um
botox and fillers for the first time in
my life and there is bruising that
happens where the needle goes in so i
got a little bit of a lip filler on top
um
yeah and that's what caused the bruising
yeah
so if you guys are wondering like wait
isn't she 38 but she looks 36 now it's
because of the botox
yeah so
um i've been contemplating the idea for
a really really long time yeah and you
know i was like well this is part of the
aging process like why am i like
yeah why am i gonna go against it right
but then i was like but wait
i'm [ __ ] i love vanity like i miss
your wrinkles fine i'm like then why why
dye my hair
then why do you exercise for the reason
that i do it right like i partially
exercise obviously for being i want to
be capable and healthy but because i
look dull yeah it is to slow down aging
yeah and it's like one
baby wait not yet
hey i gotta fix it it's not connected
it's not connected
um and then i was like then why do i
spend money on clothes and on um makeup
and i'm like yeah f that if i can
control what i look like i'm going to
control it until i can anymore so that's
true
that was the ultimate deciding factor
for me because i've been thinking about
it for a minute
um kind of going back and forth and then
i was like wait a minute
this is available yeah and it dissolves
yeah um it's been around for such a long
time i haven't seen any and you might as
well try it and you're like maybe i like
it maybe i don't yeah even with the
fillers right like uh that was one of
the things i i was like oh i don't want
to do it because as you can see it kind
of sticks out a little bit that is going
to change as
uh the swelling well i'm not that
swollen anymore because it looks like to
be honest really yeah um
but let's say i don't like it yeah then
i can get it dissolved yeah so it's all
reversible yeah so that's what the
bruising and i can't believe i didn't
bring it up earlier i'm sure there's
like a couple videos of like this
bruising but that's where it's from
i was gonna make a dumb joke but
don't do it
thank you
okay so you guys missed
what just happened so we
so the engineer father here all he did
was just put it on the seat i thought
but i already have a much
better improve plan
that's what i was gonna do but i thought
you were smarter than me said that it
was something better yeah tyga just
turned he busted a u
but it works
it's amazing dude i've never seen it
done better than this before this is the
best work i've ever seen
good job dude
i love you
alpha's birthday about you
so as you can see we are taking down all
of our christmas stuff
taking the lights off the trees
the lights off the wall look at the door
where
what
why is there one right there
did you shoot one you bikini
oh yeah all that christmas stuff over
there
all going away and this is probably the
earliest we've ever done it because
still january usually we do wait what we
wait till may
is that what happens yeah
hey um
yeah i tried i try to prolong this
process i know we love christmas but
dude i love this tree so much this one
set it up in like minutes yeah we got
this what like three four years ago yeah
and it's been good
wow baby let's see baby
okay don't do that yeah don't do that
you might break the handle off
you're gonna hurt yourself don't be
don't be silly or junky poop sorry pop
mama
yeah
yeah
ew how
what's your problem yeah look at your
face look at this dude zoom on your face
you're disgusting
[Music]
you put it in his face not on purpose
well on purpose
how do you go from not on purpose to on
purpose so he was you know he does the
stainway chases around after me in the
kitchen all the time and so this time i
walked to the side
and i purposely went like this
like that
and then right when he came to come play
drums on my butt that's when i let one
out right right
another
yeah you did he started playing drums on
my butt
[Music]
wait what
what did i tell you about peepee and
stuff what did it tell you
well can you touch other people's pee
pee
can they touch your pee pee no can you
touch their butt oh can they touch your
butt
then what happened i don't know
you stop farting on people you stop
touching people in their private parts
that's disgusting fine
next time i'm going to do the same thing
at you
okay no no more farting on people that's
disgusting because that's payback time
you hear that
that's the guy upstairs
about to take a shower
getting ready
for a brand new week
and so will we
so we will see you guys tomorrow good
night